there was one of the creepiest corporate
presentations i've ever seen in my life
just came out from microsoft
listen to how these
software spokesmen begin their
presentation
hello and welcome to microsoft ignite
we've got a big day ahead and lots in
store for you
first we want to acknowledge that the
land where the microsoft campus is
situated was traditionally occupied by
the sammamish the duwamish the
snoqualmie the tsukuamish the
muckleshoot the snohomish the tulalip
and other coast salish peoples since
time immemorial a people that are still
here continuing to honor and bring to
light their ancient heritage
my name is allison wines i'm a senior
program manager in our developer tools
division i'm an asian white female with
dark brown hair wearing a red sleeveless
top
and i'm seth juarez program manager of
the ai platform group i'm a tall
hispanic male wearing a blue shirt khaki
pants today we kick off two days of
learning more about the latest solutions
exploring how these key innovations can
empower you to do great things and
connecting with peers from around the
world
huh
what what was that
first okay let's take it backwards
forward
from the end to the beginning
they say i'm an asian lady and i'm a
sort of white guy and i
why do i care why do i care about your
race and you're talking about the
clothing you're wearing oh it's for
i think it's for blind people
i think they're doing this for blind
people because identity politics doesn't
work for blind people because they can't
see and they genuinely don't they
literally don't see color but that
doesn't work for the left because the
left needs to make every single thing
about race and these kind of physical
attributes of identity and so they've
actually got to tell you be like hey hey
hey i'm a black guy treat me differently
hey i know you can't see me and you
don't care but i am
you should treat me differently based on
my race okay and they open up they say
we're here on the land of the shumatami
muskatuzy people and they it goes on
this whole list who cares
when i go to the bronx
i do not often hear you know the puerto
rican guy in the bronx say hi i'm a
puerto rican guy wearing you know jeans
and a t-shirt and i am acknowledging
that i'm standing on land that was once
inherited by black guys and before that
by sicilian guys and before that by the
irish and before that who care what do i
care
you're in america you're standing on
you're standing on the microsoft campus
land now run by microsoft but it's this
it has to be this constant preening sort
of guilt by the way i don't think this
little acknowledgement makes the
musketeers feel any better that they
lost their land hundreds of years ago
let's move on buddy this is this world
that's how that's how the world works
it's so the reason i even bring it up
is to show though this is not about
this is not about
the government big government you know
one of the big
unfortunate events that came after the
the big virginia win is that the
establishment republicans tried to make
this all about socialism it's all just a
rejection of social socialism did not
play a single role in the virginia
election
okay it was about
culture it was about critical race
theory it was about transgender ideology
in schools it was it's not even just
about the government it's about micros i
don't want my corporations pushing this
crap and upending my traditions and my
society and
ripping america apart at the seams and
so if it's the government doing that
then let's go after the government if
it's corporations i'm happy to go after
the corporations too and that's a big
difference between the
the impotent
talking points of the republican party
for the past
20 years
and what's going on today how did you
like that clip did you like it i hope
you liked it if you did maybe you leave
me a comment maybe you ring that bell
maybe you get those notifications more
importantly though
head on over to apple podcasts or
spotify or google play
or stitcher or your record player in
your living room or wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review i greatly appreciate it we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you